Film Courage: What confuses
a new screenwriter the most?
Daniel Calvisi, Script Doctor, Writing Coach
and Author: I think it's voice on the page.
It is selecting a word choice that captures tone
and style and develop developing their original
voice on the page. It's a big thing, it is not
totally quantifiable. I mean it's you can't really
teach someone their voice. It's literally which
words do you choose in a description paragraph to
capture the moment and I think new writers don't
quite get how important tone is, how important it
is to capture the style and tone of a moment
of an individual scene or even just a second
of screen time they should think as if they're
watching that movie or TV show at that moment,
what would the what would the audience feel in
that moment? Then try and recreate that with words
on the page. It might apply to paragraph breaks,
punctuation might help, white space versus text,
everything adds up to creating the tone of that
particular scene and the pace and the style.
You can't fully teach that but I can give them
enough notes and even edits and I can say here's
how you might rewrite this description maybe if
you were use a word that's a little bit stronger
here, this one seems a little flat. I can push
them in that direction and then hopefully they'll
get into the groove and feel their voice on
the page and it'll get to be second hand.
Film Courage: Do you ever have a writer
think that they have a distinct voice but
it turns out they're really emulating
their favorite author or screenwriter?
Dan: It happens, it happens. I've had
writers write like really staccato short
description lines and it's kind of just too much,
it's too choppy. So the opposite of that is those
big thick description paragraphs you don't want
those either but you do want kind of a balance
between smaller description paragraph maybe just
one line of description maybe a bigger one use
white space It should flow you don't want too
long of monologues in your dialogue it is hard
to quantify but the page a good comedy page feels
different and maybe even looks different than a
good biopic page what are the biggest mistakes
you see made over and over again in screenplays
I would say not capturing tone the tone of
the scene in both description and dialogue
having characters not have
distinctive voices in their dialogue
too long pacing's too slow on the nose dialogue
not getting us into the story as fast as possible
because when that reader starts your script from
the get-go they want to know what the story is
what what is the concept what is the engine what
am I watching and it doesn't mean you have to
launch the engine at the bottom of page one of
course you can let it play out and take some time
and surprise us but just know that you can't have
30 pages of just set up before you even introduce
any of the main engines or main story elements
we're looking for what makes this unique and
what is the journey we're going to follow
can you explain what engine means an engine is
a character pursuing a goal against obstacles
and it's preceded usually by a catalyst so
they're thrown into a situation in which
they're now pursuing a goal and there
are antagonistic forces against them
it usually your goals internal and external
those are both engines so will the hero
defeat the villain that's your external engine
they're they're fighting to catch the villain
and the villain is fighting against them or
there's other factors in the way obstacles
and then external will they reunite with
their spouse okay so that's more of an
emotional maybe romantic engine but it's still
an engine they want to win back their spouse
and there are obstacles in between so you can
call that an engine what's driving the story
with a TV series I like to define the compelling
crisis which is like the core of the drama it's
the core problem that that show is showcasing and
it's usually an engine it's will this character
achieve this against these obstacles
it's kind of a mini log line if you will
so you want to know what that core crux problem
is you probably want one in in a in a pilot you
want an A and A-B story definitely you might have
a C and a D story, you probably don't want to have
also an E, F, G, H, I, J story you don't
want to have too many engines going
unless it's a multi-character piece like White
Lotus like the White Lotus but even there I
think you really only have four separate engines
four separate camps with the different characters
I think in season two maybe they added there were
more characters there was more going on but that's
a specific type of story and it's an ensemble
piece it's a multi-character and those are
tougher to write but that is a route you could go
can we define what tone is can we give an example
tone in screenplays is really word choice to
create the feeling of a scene and it's hard to
quantify because there's a billion words you could
use to capture a certain scene and that's really
the special sauce that the writer brings what
words punctuation black versus white space on
the page are they going to use to capture that
tone but if you think of I mean so something
like get out which has a creepy scary tone that's
probably going to look different on the page than
as good as it gets and it's hard it depends on
the example of course but I'm always trying to
help my writers with the tone in the page just
saying if this is horror or should we be scared
right now should we not and sometimes with newer
writers it's hard to tell they're using different
they're using kind of maybe more matter-of-fact
words when I when I I'll say well maybe use
stronger words maybe cut this sentence off with
a dash and so what's coming next will feel more
abrupt and maybe we picture it on our head
different I've always have the projector going
in my head I'm always picturing the scenes playing
on the screen as anyone does when they're reading
a screenplay they should be you're picturing
the movie or the TV show that's playing out so
you want them to picture it as much as close
as possible to your version of the movie
that's impossible to do and that's why
you don't want to direct on the page you
don't want to use directorial terms pan
left and and close up extreme close-up
you don't want to write like the
director like right camera references
because really you can't you can't explain how
a scene looks or how a shot looks you couldn't
really if I explained a shot of a desert it
doesn't mean you would think of it exactly
like it appeared in Lawrence of Arabia we
would have different thoughts about what
that desert shot looked like so you don't want
to try that much go that far to over explain
but word choice is really really important and
tone and feeling Stephen Spielberg always said
when he's listening to a pitch he says what
is the audience feeling now so I want to know
how it would feel if I was the audience member of
this script I'm reading so if I'm reading a script
let's say for the swingers and I don't really
know the movie versus The Hangover the two tones
are definitely getting even though there's like a
similarity with some of it not totally but there's
going to be an obvious difference in this tone
if it really works I'm going to feel a different
there should be yeah yeah I mean those are both
comedies so maybe those are a little close but
if you look at Coen Brothers scripts No Country
for Old Men has some really interesting kind of
literary text they use a lot of kind of more
lofty language in their descriptions than you
would normally use in a script and they use a lot
of description more than I think probably a new
unestablished writer should use but if you get
a chance to read No Country for Old Men that's
really interesting Whiplash by Damien Chazelle
that has some really interesting tonal choices
yeah it's all about the words that you choose
that's writing can you tell the difference between
a screenplay where the goal is just to sell it
versus the goal is to tell a compelling story
so usually the one that they're only
writing because they want to sell it you
just don't feel passion for the story it's
usually flatter it's just written flatter
there might be elements thrown in that come
out of nowhere they're not motivated I mean
motivation is huge and I feel like it gets more
and more important for me the more scripts I read
more books I read and the more movies I watch
the more motivated actions are in a script
just the better I don't know why but film
is a visual medium and you want to see
if your character does something or they come upon
something we kind of want set up for it we want to
have something be motivated we want to know we
want to know why or how they got to this point
and a lot of beginner screenplays it's too
random it's not necessarily motivated I
hear a lot of screenwriters tell me but this
happened to me in real life this just random
thing happened to me in real life that happens
right well movies and TV shows aren't random
dramatic visual storytelling is not random as an
audience we do want to see why something happens
we want to see the setup of it breadcrumbs
leading up to the reveal setups before payoffs
lighting the bomb before the bomb goes
off so motivation and setup are very key
they're left out of a lot of modern work I think
too much I find that I'm too confused when I
watch especially a lot of newer films they throw
you into the story too fast we're entering the
story too late and we have to catch up and put
together what's going on who are these people
is that their job where are they you don't
want to start off with your audience confused
they can be interested and compelled to find out
more but if they're confused and they just don't
know what the hell's going on that's not
a good place to be anywhere in the script.